foreign
[Music]
like making all that noise so uh yeah
Tom had to go in there and comment about
my boob window yeah yeah and then Zach
says is that like a glory hole for tits
where people pass through five dollars
and then reach in and grab them no I
hope not now the boob Windows this is
the boob window I mean you'd have to
give me a lot more than five dollars to
be able to like reach in there and do
that you know maybe if you gave me like
a hundred dollars or 500 just for a feel
no that's a little too much I think huh
well I'm offended okay all right well
I'm trying to think of the market value
of how many [__] customers
I'll be back there [__] seven tickets
of course you will
because you would totally do that you
don't you don't care if you're the group
I'm like as long as you're getting paid
30 a piece you probably get more of them
well you know
I don't know what the boob Market is
today we're gonna gotta get some traffic
through here he's gonna pimp me out no
yeah I mean we're yeah we're going to
mannequins tonight so it's like I don't
really want most of those [__]
anywhere near me I'm ready you're ready
I'm ready
I'm ready any kind if I got a fight or
anything I'm ready I mean hope not we
know some people that are going tonight
so yeah we'll have we'll have friendly
people there Dave will be there yeah
Dave will be there yeah uh you know so
Danny Rowling said do any guys still
wear those all black colored contacts if
not that [__] needs to make a comeback
yeah is that around um yeah I haven't
seen any in a while but yeah I think I
mean they're still around people still
wear them
yeah they kind of do depends on the
event that's a special event [__] yeah
most people will do it for like a
special event if it's like you know the
vampire ball or some [__] like that yeah
that's when you go in full drag
yeah we're just like tonight is just
kind of like we're going to mannequin so
I'm doing the corset and stuff but I'm
not getting like super super fancy you
know what I'm saying
uh Jeffy art says your window is
definitely worth a cool million tax free
thank you very much see
that's what you that's what you got
changed he's simping
that's okay trying to get some [__] for
free man [__] just you know just like
on [__] stream mate the more they
talk the more free [__] they're trying
everybody trying to get [__] for free on
there right because you really gotta
watch you really gotta watch the dudes
that don't say anything they just
[__] bam go private money starts
coming your way you know that dude's all
about [__] those those are the real
players remember that remember that
remember that thing we had the other day
where this guy came on and all he said
was I have a very specific fantasy yeah
and I was like okay tell me what it is
it sounded hokey as [__] well yeah we
did it though yeah we did it anyway
[Music]
it wasn't that it wasn't that weird I
had to pretend I was like some tribal
dude who would [__] I I was a queen
right and you were a tribal dude that
had captured me yeah like a queen of the
dab Wonder Woman type right like the
Amazons Amazons and [__] and like you
were gonna kill all of my handmaidens if
you didn't do whatever if I didn't do
what you said yeah right that went on
for about what 20 minutes yeah 15
seconds and we I just had to like make
it up like yeah it was kind of fun yeah
I think he paid 6.99 a minute didn't it
yeah I think that was exclusive right it
was exclusive I think it's a little bit
exclusive so 7.99
no I think I think ours is private is
5.99 and exclusive to 6.99 I think oh it
is I think it's a dollar more now
I'd go back and look yeah we'll check
the price I mean I was the one that
changed it so I'm pretty sure that I
remember what it is okay
Danny Rowling said the chestical credit
card swipe yeah that's right just just
going in there Sebastian says I have
7.56 if that will do
I mean for a minute I mean hey that's
better than nothing
uh Zach says Tom how do you look with
those goggles actually on they look good
hold on
let's find out yeah where
yeah there you go
you look like you're about to do Death
Race 2000. one of the war boys and [__]
Fury Road witness me yeah yes I actually
don't wear these on motorcycles though
no no I wear these weed eating
the tea really I've ever seen
that's really funny I don't blame you
though because like shift lies in your
eyes you know
Zach says also have you guys ever heard
of that couples game where one writes
dirty words on the other person's back
and they have to guess what it is no I
have never heard of that game
I've never heard of that game
thank you very much Ian England be
careful sitting next to that firecracker
top
yeah yeah he's just gonna she smells
good too yeah she's got that damn Jimmy
Jimmy Choo perfect
yeah yeah it does smell really good yeah
she wasn't cheap either it was not it
was very exciting yeah but um but yeah
it's really nice though it's kind of
vanilla flavored with it's vanilla
Jasmine mandarin orange yeah and two
other things yeah it's kind of like
a sweeter version of [__] obsession
it kind of reminded me of us and it was
funny because it was the first one I
picked pretty much yeah
that one that bottle and I said I never
I didn't know who Jimmy Choo was or
anything that had a feeling about that
one and smelled it and I go that's it
right there that's that's that's that's
the fragrance for Jim
yeah benches at 130 bucks a bottle it is
yeah but you know I've said that but you
don't have to use that much you don't
use that much at all I just usually do
one spray and it like lasts for a long
time yeah and and the sales girl was
like well we there's a new version of
that out you know yeah because this
one's called I want chew I want you yeah
yeah it just is a new version of it was
I smelled that it was like nah I mean
that one was good too but the first one
I liked the first one about her yeah
because we we messed around with them
because I'm like look I don't usually
you know I'm I'm a broke ass person and
so I would usually just buy like cheap
ass and we went to like bed uh not Bed
Bath and Beyond what the [__] am I
talking about um Bath and Body Works
close
um some cheap [__] and yeah and like
smelled some stuff in there and some of
that stuff it smells good but Tom's like
you need some good stuff he's like you
don't really have any nice perfume and
you know and I was like well I don't
even know what to pick and I have
certain things that I like but he's like
you need is like a signature fragrance
yeah because your signature fragrance is
Obsession like Obsession for Men that's
this that's the smell that I always
associate that's the gayest name of all
times
you do though yeah
exactly oh yeah me too me too right no
but I just that men's Obsession I
[__] I've always liked it I love it
I'll be back in the 90s I [__] it's a
90s fragrance you know it is yeah the
cologne you know but I associate it with
you because that's what you always wore
it like when I met you and it's just
kind of like and it just works on you
really well yeah and it just permeates
everything yeah like all your clothes
smelled like that so it always just like
whenever I smell it like I'm always like
oh it's time you know what I mean yeah
so what the good thing about it is that
it's not an old man smell yeah it
doesn't smell like [__] Old Spice or
some [__] even though I smelled some of
that new Old Spice this cheap [__] I
smelled it recently that the uh and it
actually smells pretty good some of the
news yeah I mean some of it does smell
good it's cheap but it smells the
problem is with cheap fragrances they
don't last yeah you gotta use more you
gotta use a lot of they don't last yeah
you got to be putting it on all day
the more expensive stuff I mean over
time it just permeates all your [__]
clothes
you don't smell it whatever other people
do well yeah it's like I spray I put one
Spritz on like last night and then like
this morning you were like oh you smell
like this
[Laughter]
I was aroused
this right yeah we probably Prime but
I'm gonna just gonna [__] Mass plane
okay Tom spleen
a man will remember the way you smell
and he doesn't even realize it
smell is very very powerful yeah and I
don't think people realize I'll be just
[__] walking
just through a mall or in a club and all
of a sudden catch a whiff of some chicks
fragrance and I will immediately have
flashes of having sex with some chick
back in the 80s or 90s girlfriend type
[__] you know and and I don't and it's
in and it's [__] in um it's not uh
what do you call it and I would have
forgot all about her right you know what
I mean it's it's what do you call it
it's uh
it's automatic not a lot of it it's you
know when you have like a [__] your
your reflexes it's what do you call it
um in
involuntary involuntary yeah
get old you forget words yeah you just
have an involuntary response
as well as memories come back yeah and
that's sexual memory and Center very
closely yeah right and I'll [__] have
a flashback and [__] and I see that
girl's face I'll remember her name that
smell [__] what happened on that day
just it'll it'll all come back just
because that one's sick yeah even though
you didn't like never thought of her in
[__] 20 something years right yeah
and really she wasn't that important but
the that smell somehow gets yeah it just
triggers it yeah
so if that's a [__] important weapon
in a [__] woman's Arsenal trying to
control these [__]
because that's what you smell like is
[__] very important
he won't forget that smell yeah
it's animal
and I feel like I didn't really like I
said I didn't really usually wear a lot
of perfume or anything before like I
didn't associate her with any kind of
smell well yeah because usually what I
would do because like I said I'm I was
broke ass so I'd have like this
subscription service and sometimes they
would send me different scents and if I
liked them I'd be like oh I'd use that
for like a few months until it was gone
and then like I'd get another one but I
wasn't like super invested in any of
them yeah anymore it's just like yeah
this is okay they were okay stuff they
weren't super high quality right right
that [__] that you got on now man that
[__] [__] dominates yeah I mean she
gets in bed with that [__] and it hits
me and I was like oh
[Laughter]
you know I mean I [__] start growling
yeah
breaking up yeah yeah over
he does give it up
[Laughter]
that [__] up
you're adorable
yeah it does smell really really nice
yeah so I'm glad we found one because
like I said I was I didn't really you
know I don't really keep up with all the
perfumes and stuff like that so I was
just kind of like we were just like
trying out all the Samplers I'm like
some of these are nice but it's just
kind of like I don't know it's I don't
love it but this one I was we were both
like we sprayed it and we were like oh
yeah that's it the Tom and Jenny seal of
approval those
to Jimmy Choo I want you I want you it
comes in like a big red sparkly box this
chew is spelled c-h-o-o yeah right yeah
like I said he's pretty famous that's a
pretty good yeah designer house or
whatever yeah it does smell really good
I can't remember what the other two
scents are and it's it's a vanilla base
and then it's got mandarin orange and
it's got Jasmine and then it's got
another flower and another fruit yeah is
it Peach yeah it had peach in it maybe
it's Peach and then I can't remember
what the other flower is then it has
another flower but I can't remember what
Orchid no Violet now
I'll remember like later on I can't
remember
but yeah it smells really good it's
because I don't like
um I I kind of like more musky scents I
don't like overly floral I don't like
super sweet I do kind of like vanilla or
kind of candy flavor but not if it's too
much you know what I mean I tend to like
more musky or like leathery scents or
something like that
so this one yeah but this one is good
because it's like it has flour and it
has fruit and stuff like that in it but
the way that they put them together you
can't smell it right you can't really
tell like that there's no not one
dominating yeah like oh that's vanilla
or oh that's you know you can smell it
if you know that it's in there but if
you don't then you don't know which is
it's just it's it's its own smell which
you know it's just kind of a warm smell
yeah the only way I can describe it yeah
that's exactly what it is yeah warm and
comforting but it's also kind of like uh
pushes a man to do things that he may
not want to do
say you don't want to say you don't want
to might be some [__] explicit sexual
[__]
and you know and you don't want to do
that who knows that [__] might be some
kind of weird anal [__]
you're like I don't want you I'm gonna
have to take
[Laughter]
because he has you know you regulars
know Jenny's always trying to [__]
fantasize about all this kinky ass [__]
and it's funny we'll be on stream mating
these dudes are [__] asking me to
Dish
and sometimes we wonder if it's like one
of you guys and so you you know what's
from uh
or is it just sick coincidence that
people are coming in there want me to
get pegged yeah
they're like so you don't have enough
money it doesn't get you laughing though
yeah I was laughing well what kind of
money you talking about I was saying
like like [__] motorcycle yeah like
buy me a car
[Laughter]
so then then maybe he'll think about it
well you scared that dick yeah I'm
[__] terrified
I mean at least
if you're not terrified of that dick
then [__] you need to go hang out
with Zach
he's a [__] dick Kamikaze because I
told you I told you it would just be me
it's not gonna be like it's not scary
and he's like oh that's even scarier
she's trying to [__] weasel her way
out here she's what they call a sneaky
[__]
you gotta watch it you gotta keep your
eye on it I know yeah I'm gonna I like I
said I would never do anything against
your will I'll just I'll just try to
like talk him into it it's like a
superhero's got like like a superheroes
go outside kick
Zach said that [__]
idiokana and I'm here for if he's that
you got me Tom I don't know what he's
like
I'm going back reading these comments
yeah and I don't know exactly what
they're reacting to because I said so
much [__]
he's ever heard a couple okay then yeah
I said that already okay yeah early
you're behind Okay now yeah Zach talking
about re-zack it's only been he's
obsessed with yeah the only man I'm
obsessed with are at the moment are
Barry and Robin Gibb not Maurice though
he doesn't have enough hair yeah poor
Maurice
I get it though I get it like I said I
kind of like meetings are we gonna
review saw X pro I don't know maybe
honestly I've only seen the first saw I
don't think I've seen any of the other
one no maybe I saw the second one yeah I
did see the second one but I don't
really remember that much about it I'm
not really into that slash [__]
I mean the first Saw movie is good and
like some of the other ones I heard were
good like I know what they're you know I
I know what happens in all of them and
[__] but
I don't think I've ever sat down and
watched all of them I can't believe
they're on the tenth one already that's
[__] crazy
Zach says I had a bottle of this George
Clooney cologne that was so good even my
mom wore it a few times
and then Camp guy said hi karate oh my
God I remember I remember that [__] very
funny TV commercials from the 1970s for
the scent a regular guy puts on the
scent and then he spends the whole
commercial fighting off women I remember
that my dad had that yeah that was a big
that was a thing yeah it came in for a
black bottle for a moment
I remember that I remember and I
remember in the 80s what was that one uh
what was that one cent by Prince
matchabelli or whatever that commercial
was on all the time too but I can't
remember the name of it
but there were yeah there's like certain
I guess there's certain [__] sensor
associated with certain decades I
remember the one didn't like Elizabeth
Taylor haven't like white diamonds or
some [__] I mean they I think they still
sell that because when we were at the
department store the other day they had
it
but I don't even remember what that
smells like my grandma had some
but I kind of I associate that with like
a grandma scent although it smells good
but
you know it's just everyone's dream to
get to see Tom get picked I guess it is
like I said so we never know because we
do get that sometimes like people come
in streamate and be like so pegging
and um Tom will be like God damn it are
you like from the Regular Show oh it
might just be that a lot of people want
to see that I don't really know it's
like hard to say
um Ricky Martin was pretty hot for a guy
yeah he was I kind of I remember that
uh Zach said I don't think I've ever met
a person who actually wore any of those
Elizabeth Taylor perfumes I don't think
I have either like I said my grandmother
had some but I don't know if she ever
wore it I mean she might have just got
it like as a present from somebody
I don't know but that's yeah that's one
that's very 80s that I remember
and I don't and like I said I don't
really keep track of like all like
what's the trends and the perfumes and
everything like that so I don't really
know like which ones people
associate with old people
say anything's associated with old
people anymore because they're all dead
maybe like I said we were at the
department store the other day and they
do have a lot of ones that I remembered
like from my childhood so some of them
are still
are still out there Classics now I
remember in the 80s and 90s everybody
was into man what's that one what's that
cologne
oh [__] I just totally forgot the name
of it that everybody was super into
dracar Noir like you remember when
everybody was was wearing that yeah that
[__] wasn't that expensive though that
[__] it wasn't no like it smelled pretty
good but I remember everybody wearing
that yeah it's like a lower
it was like a mid price you know what I
mean you could get that for 40 bucks
back then
in a pretty decent sized bottle
yeah Jeff hard said my mom used to wear
white diamonds yeah uh Camp guy said I
like there's one called Lauren on a on a
girl very heavy Rose Floral scent see I
would like that I like rose uh sense
also
Danny Rowling said if someone paid you
to take Tom's load in your mouth and
spit it back into his face would you
actually do it because that would be
funny as [__] to see Tom's reaction to
that
if stuff to be staged we'd have to know
that if you know yeah you'll be part of
it well if somebody was paying yeah yeah
but like I said yes the job you know
what I'm talking about right it's just a
part of the Casual we'll do pretty well
I don't want to say that I said we'll do
like pretty much anything within reason
yeah there's some [__] that come people
come in and go can you do this like and
we don't have the [__] for it you know
because some people are like what bro
some of this [__] is like well that
takes to do that that takes about a half
hour to get ready and [__] we don't
really want to do that doesn't somebody
want you to put your dick in a vacuum
cleaner yeah dude try to give you the
[__] back it's like I just kind of
laughed it off it was one of those
there's a certain class of [__] dude
that
that's on stream mate to ask you a lot
of questions and tries to get you
talking and tries to get you to leave
and come back with something like shoes
that [__] will Vash it's just a
power play yeah he won't he wanted me to
go get a go get the vacuum cleaner right
and bring it on the camera and then he'd
check out and then he would leave yeah
yeah so we're we're on to that game yeah
[Laughter]
like I said everybody's trying to get
[__] for free and they're always trying
to
they'll they'll come in with a you know
ostensibly to be like oh do you guys do
this like a specific fetish or something
like that yeah and if you say yeah we
can do that or something then they'll
try to get you to talk about it yeah and
they're jerking it while they're talking
right they just want you because they
don't want to pay Steve they just want
you to like talk about it because that
gets them off and I'm just like yeah no
I'm not doing that if you shut that down
by saying yeah we do that but we'll
we'll talk about that in private yeah
yeah when they're shutting in the break
and then they leave and then they leave
which is fine because you don't want
them wasting your time like I said I'm
not sitting here for [__] free
[__] it's like you better [__]
if you pay you know yeah so it's that
um Zach says uh how do people work in
the perfume department at a mall and not
get brain damage from fumes I must go
somewhere to look like they're having
fun the the woman that sold us that was
look like a chinese-american chick maybe
Korean American
and uh she wasn't there first remember
yeah and then she came over here who
works at this table and then she came
over and [__] she made an easy sale
and then asked me if you know if you
have one of our credit cards to give you
a [__] was it 20 20. I think it was
30 30 off
so I real quick did the [__] credit
card thing and they gave me a [__]
MasterCard a real MasterCard [__]
credit card with a three thousand
dollars because your credit is good they
wouldn't give me jack [__] because my
credit's terrible and actually no my
credit is [__] excellent yeah towards
the top yeah I pay all my [__] bills
yeah well and you don't have years and
years of
uh bad credit right yeah because you
didn't have a credit card for a long
time yeah and you and then when I do
have them I I always pretty much pay
them off at the end of the month right
not have the whole thing paid off mostly
that's not doing going that way the past
couple months but I'd pay at least half
of it yeah
so yeah so they uh they gave actually
when when he applied for the card in the
store they actually said it was a 1500
limit but then when he got the card it
was actually three thousand they did a
[__] check on me
they said oh okay he's one of those he's
one of those yeah cause my [__] you
know how they got the little credit card
yeah mine's up and you're way in the
green it's you know yeah
I forgot the number
but I'm like 10 points away from perfect
yeah you know and I think I think this
thing I think the [__] scale goes up
to like 500. I don't well I'm like a
475. no it's no it's more than that
because mine's on the low end and it's
600 and something okay yeah and then
mine's like fair or something fair right
so I don't even remember what the what
the top one is as long as you pay almost
all the card off by the end of the month
or at the end of the month your credits
will be pretty good and you know if you
get in trouble where you can't make a
payment
you know like a huge payment like that
you you make like half of what you
normally would it'll it'll stay good
your credit will stay good yeah I mean
as long as you're not late you don't get
behind and [__] like that and you're
making big payments
Danny Rowling said Hugo Boss Cologne in
the green box smells the best in my
opinion I yeah I can't picture that I
know what that box looks like because
I've seen it but I can't imagine like
what it smells like I probably smelled
it at some point but but yeah I really
do like that
like that Jimmy Choo that you got me it
smells really really good I can smell it
right now because I just yeah I just
sprayed it on and so can you probably
yeah smell it
he's getting all he's getting all growly
he's gonna do that growly
[Laughter]
but but so what else have we got to talk
about uh so
like I said it was my birthday earlier
this week
on Tuesday
and I got to because of my cool ass
siblings got to go to the Disney
Halloween party on Tuesday night and
then we went to Epcot on Wednesday so
that was super fun I hadn't been to
Epcot since
I don't know when
and they have added they're still
working on because they're refurbishing
a lot of stuff and adding a bunch of
stuff so some of the stuff is still like
under construction or whatnot
but they have added Guardians of the
Galaxy I don't know how long that that
that's been there
All My Siblings had been on it and I was
the only person that had it they're like
oh my God you have to go on it it's
amazing so we I mean it took a while
like it's a long wait but holy [__] that
was a great [__] ride that's a great
[__] ride she said the Tron ride was
good too yeah it's not quite as good as
guardians but yeah tron's at Disney
and um it looks super cool especially at
night because we were there at night but
I mean we got there in the daytime we
got there at like four o'clock but then
like the party started at seven and we
went on
um Tron and it's just kind of like it's
right next to Space Mountain and it's
all this huge big dome and it's all like
lit up blue underneath and like this
it's a roller coaster only complaint I
had about it was it's kind of short
like you wait a while
it wasn't that long of a wait but um the
ride itself is not very long but as you
know Space Mountain the ride isn't that
long either roller coasters aren't very
aren't known for being super long rides
but the thing about Guardians of the
Galaxy though because the Tron one is
cool because you
um it's a roller coaster but it's like
it's like two light cycles like next to
each other and there's like a bunch of
them so you sit on it like you'd sit on
a sport bike like a motorcycle
um you know so you're leaning forward
and like with your legs behind you like
that so that kind of gives it a little
bit of a different vibe but see the
Guardians of the Galaxy one not only is
that almost completely it's not
completely in the dark but a lot of it
is in the dark
um but that roller coaster not only goes
forward it also goes backward and each
section each two-person section of the
cars spins so it's like so sometimes
when it's it'll go up and around like
that and then you'll be like spinning
like that at the same time so it's like
it's a very intense experience did you
announce that we were going to
mannequins
um I put on um on Dave's post because
Dave posted about it that he was going
and I said I just sat on there that we
were going to I'm gonna go ahead and
post
okay
maybe it'll get more people to come yeah
Zach said what's the weirdest dream you
had lately I'd love to write a story
with dream logic
um
I'm trying to remember I had a weird one
the other day but now I can't remember
what it was
most of my dreams are kind of boring to
be honest I had this really weird dream
that I was like in this City it was kind
of like New York City but it wasn't
exactly and I was with my friend like
some girl I don't know who the [__] she
was really in real life but um it was
kind of weird and it wasn't like all
that Sinister or anything but then like
we got in a cab and we were going to
leave like we were going back over the
bridge or whatever and the car went off
the bridge
and into the water and it was like
really Vivid like that I was in the back
seat next to this girl and we were
looking at each other like holy [__]
because we couldn't get out of the car
and like it just kept
um it was kind of like a Carnival of
Souls you know what I mean like that's
what it reminded me of and so I'm like
in the car and the water is coming up
and coming up and like that and like the
water went over my head and then I woke
up so that like freaked me the [__] out
and I couldn't go back to sleep you know
uh Camp guy said they don't have that
much room next to Space Mountain
um I didn't think so either because when
we went my sister and I
went to the Halloween party at Disney
last year last September and they were
building Tron then
so and they had it cleared out and they
kind of constructed it and I but I
couldn't like picture what it was gonna
look like
so it's only been there for like less
than a year
but it's pretty big it's like a big
Pavilion it's kind of cool because you
can go up and it's like all of this open
like concrete kind of area like you go
up these like uh like steps and um like
ramps and stuff and it's just this big
open area and this big dome and then
part for part of the ride you're outside
so you can watch the people going around
on the track like with the lighted up
light cycles it's pretty cool like my
brother took a bunch of pictures of it
and we got a picture of because they
take pictures on all the rides now and
my brother is a PhotoPass guy and so he
automatically gets all the pictures you
know they're linked to his account
so whenever there was a picture taken of
us on whatever ride whether it was TRON
or the Haunted Mansion or whatever like
it would immediately like upload to his
phone
so he could show them to us and they
were high res because you know like I
said he's a PhotoPass guy so that's one
of his things so he
he sent me the picture of me and my
sister-in-law because it was me and my
sister-in-law Emily and we were like
sitting next to each other on the late
cycles and he sent us a picture the
picture that was from inside a Tron and
it's like I'm just sitting there like
screaming and uh my sister-in-law like
has her hands all up like that I
wouldn't do that I was like too scared
to put my hands up I'm like I'm not
letting go of the [__] handlebars on
this [__] no way no way
you're coming up on TV
she's like okay look at that little face
yeah
she just loves any kind of attention
she's like as long as you're petting me
and not banned as long as I got
intention and [__] Bam's not around
[Laughter]
anytime yeah they do they're playing in
the morning and stuff but if you if she
ever sees you like if you're petting
Bambi
um Pookie will come in and just like sit
and stare yeah like what what the [__]
why are you petting that kitty yeah and
she'll just like sit there and stare at
you and then she'll be like
all the way right down next to each
other though they do though they're not
yeah they don't and they've Chase each
other and kind of like smack around and
stuff like that they just but they're
not fighting they're just like having
them they're just
what was that all about books it's like
stop it stop it she's just trying to get
attention she's trying to bite what you
bite why you bite because it's adventure
she bites me all day long
she's like I like to bite you yeah you
like to bite poles let's just play bite
yeah
Danny Rowling says uh what did you guys
think of the film phone booth I don't
think I saw it I remember hearing about
it but I don't think I ever sat down and
watched it was it good or bad or worthy
of reviewing
um
there should be a sequel taking place in
Austria because they still use phone
booths yeah I haven't seen a phone booth
in a really long time
um matter of fact I was somewhere where
the [__] was I the other day I was in a
building the other day and there was pay
phones it was like a little Bank of pay
phones I'm like holy [__] why are those
still in here they probably don't work
huh maybe not I mean it's I guess
they're good to have around just in
emergencies like if you're cell phoned
and like breaks or some [__] like that
bombs have a cell phone
it was just weird because I hadn't seen
one for such a long time
only time you see a pay phone in the
south is out in the parking lot the side
of the parking lot of an abandoned
service station yeah
they're there yeah I don't really even
yeah
that's why I was so surprised to see
them
like in that building because
well no I take that back when I was at
Epcot we were waiting for my brother to
get there because he had the passes like
to get us all in
and so we were waiting out front like
outside the gate and there's like a like
a thing of bathrooms and [__] and I'm
pretty sure there was a pay phone over
there like just one just for emergencies
I guess and I was just kind of like hey
look at that so I thought that was
pretty weird
yeah Camp guys next to a Korea so it's
soaked telephone pole yeah and there's
um you know I think even the abandoned
gas stations around here you don't
really see them
and it's weird how they disappeared so
gradually that it's like I don't even
remember
them taking them out or anything like
that so it must have been like years and
years ago that they went away I never
even because no one even like really
noticed that you don't see them anymore
until you're go you're around somewhere
and you see one and you're like oh my
God and you realize you haven't seen one
in such a long time
and also when I was at Epcot I was in
the UK Pavilion and they have fake
you know the fake red telephone boxes in
there I don't think there's really
phones in there I didn't look but um but
yeah they have those but those are just
like for atmosphere you know what I mean
so it looks like
and I don't know if they still have
those in the UK or not
because I haven't been there in a long
time
Zach said talking about dreams I had one
the other night where I was a spy or
something that is kind of weird had this
female colleague with me and we were at
a hotel with some really pretty swamps
around it trying to break into a museum
next door to steal some Nazi artifacts
or something that's pretty awesome you
should write a story about that you
should write a story about that
uh yeah Danny rolling said it in
Australia I think they're free
really
I mean I guess they might as well be
nowadays it's not like one it you'd only
ever have to use it in an emergency
probably and if you had to use in an
emergency like who the [__] even has
change anymore nobody
so either they'd have to like let you
use your debit card
or it would be free
thank you thank you thank you
little mover I think that says okay
sorry I'm very very blind
um thank you very much became a fan
because of Jenny's flickers of fear and
been obsessed with all of y'all's videos
ever since working up the courage to be
more active well hey welcome welcome to
take courage to the weird little family
[Laughter]
the weird little sidetracks family
where we just kind of hang out on Friday
night and drink and we don't want to
drink too much because like I said we're
going out in a little bit but you know I
mean it was a little mother I see you
baby cute little hair and everything
oh he's checking you out yeah I checked
it out
I'm gonna hook you up look
let me show you what are you gonna show
me don't show the camera no oh okay oh
okay I'm gonna hook her up with [__]
Lloyd
Lloyd the white girl Whisperer Lloyd's
got enough he's got on his plate I think
he's gonna know we were trying to go
ahead and just get you in trouble we
were talking about him on the Wednesday
show so when I was away because I was
gone from Tuesday to like Tuesday
afternoon to Wednesday night because I
stayed with my sister
uh you know at the resort
so Tom went out to Bike Night in
downtown Sanford on Tuesday night
because you know he didn't have to be
home because I wasn't here
so he he met a new bro yeah met a new
bro yeah and he texted me about it like
on Wednesday
his family owns the uh
Jamaican restaurant
downtown Sanford
yeah and uh he was an interesting
character
very interesting character yeah and uh
so I renamed him
as Lloyd the white girl Whisperer
I'll show it to you
oh he [__] it up here
you [__] it up
there you go there Lloyd
me and Lloyd
we were trying to get him to come out to
mannequins yeah but I think he has to
work because I've never met him in
person well you just met him too yeah so
yeah we hung out all night though
the uh Lloyd is 37 years old he looks
like he's 22. all right 37.
he's five foot ten
it weighs about 180 pounds
and he's um
probably 10 body fat
and the [__] got fantastic
definition he's never picked up a
[__] weight never
it's just all natural
just amazing
well there you go crazy yeah but he
wants to he's he says I want to get on
that test I want you he said he wants to
get on test
he went because he's getting older
he says I want to stay fit like this and
I said yeah that's the only way you're
going to do it over time
so I was just cooling him a little bit
he wants a lift too
put on a few more bounds
but uh he's working tonight I I told him
we're gonna be down there he's working
probably working at the restaurant
I've never eaten at that restaurant yeah
this is what I'm thinking of
I've eaten at Chantels I've eaten that
um pop what's that German one called the
holler box or whatever
um have you done a couple other ones but
I've never eaten at that one
I think Tom was also impressed because
he's married but then he also has like
all these girlfriends yeah also and the
wife apparently knows about it yeah he's
married to a white girl he's got like
four or five other ones in it and one
black one
I'm at the black one I went to school
with that one
so he's just got one for every night of
the week yeah pretty much yeah I was
[__] impressed I was [__]
impressed as [__] because that's what
when Tom told me that I was just kind of
like what are you getting tips on how to
do that and I said no he doesn't you
know I just are you trying to adopt his
nature and I'm like no I already got
that nature he's just doing it but no
they he
I think he's separated from his wife
though okay I think I think he didn't
okay but I think he's separated from oh
okay well I think he's separated from
his wife he's dating oh well that's a
whole different situation that's not how
he see he he was like a real [__]
player the way right he told it to me
right made me see it another way and
then I re-interpreted it as separated
from his wife oh okay so that's a
completely different situation
like a [__] player he reinterpreted
it to spin it to even make it look even
[__] cooler because he's like yeah my
wife doesn't give us yeah yeah right
yeah he's like well technically I'm not
really married yeah yeah so it's
probably something so like I said that's
over time it's not quite the same no I
let I let that story stand I like the
first version of it I'll let that one
stand
I like the first I like the first
version
well like I said it sounds it sounds
better it sounds cooler when you say it
like that other than I'm just dating
some I'm dating some all these little
chicks yeah yeah and then it's like
we're separated but that's right what it
was yeah probably so I just give him the
credit that was a good way of telling it
too okay then you know it is how you
describe it that's how I'm gonna send it
that's how I'm gonna imagine it okay
yeah I'm gonna accept your version of
reality
hahaha
oh [__]
Zach says by the way uh there's a movie
coming out
about it soon I think I make a good
topic uh the oh yeah the Osage tribe
murders in Oklahoma in the 20s yeah
isn't that the new um
what the hell's the name of that movie
I've seen like the trailer for it a
couple of times yeah that might make a
good
if we can kind of time it
with when the movie comes out we might
get more hits that way Camp guy said I
just saw a funny as hell Chef John video
for Halloween it's a ham and cheese hand
and arm with a knife sticking out the
top the hamstrips look like tendons in a
skinned out arm and hand oh I'm gonna
have to see that I'm all about all of
the like Halloween themed cooking shows
and baking shows and all that kind of
stuff where they have to like construct
cakes that look like Halloween [__] and
everything like that I love those I'm
like totally obsessed with those I watch
them every year I like the Christmas
ones too but the Halloween ones are
better
yeah I can't guys said he cut all the
fingers except the birdie finger when he
was taste testing it so the hand was
shooting a bird at that
those are the flower Moon that's what I
was thinking Martin's course I think
that new movie
yeah that's the thing it's just kind of
like I I'm always kind of disappointed
though because it's like sometimes they
come up with these cool ass ideas I'm
like oh my God that would be so awesome
but then sometimes they don't have time
to do it right or like it falls apart or
some [__] like that because it never
looks quite as cool as I was imagining
it was gonna look you know what I mean
sometimes it does but a lot of times
they just don't have enough time because
they're rushing so but I still like to
watch it anyway I like those I like
those kind of things
but um but yeah so
so we're not gonna have uh We're not
gonna meet the white woman Whisperer
tonight that's disappointing white girl
whisper the white girl whisper yeah it
was what it was you know he's showing me
all the pictures white girls and he goes
yeah and I said well they're eating a
black women because of course Ain't
Enough of them you know just it's just
[__] funny Banner you know not enough
not enough of them for him
you know it's mostly white ones so this
is you're the [__] one you're the
[__] white girl whisper and he goes
yeah yeah
oh my God
these dudes man how do they keep track
how do they keep track he's taming them
I guess taming them yeah like I said I
can't imagine because I know I know that
it's like every dude's fantasy to like
have a harem of women he's got a harem
that's what I'm saying so that's like so
that's like every dude's fantasy I guess
yeah but those girls should probably
date another dudes too well no yeah
that's what I mean yeah but what I was
gonna say was that I mean I got one dude
and that's plenty like I can't even
imagine how exhausted I would be if I
had to like deal with more than that
yeah you know what I'm saying so it's
like that's absolutely not yeah anything
that I would do because I know you make
jokes all the time like you're making
jokes on Wednesday about if like after I
died and you went through my email it's
like yeah I found all our boyfriends and
stuff like that I'm like okay we're
having a kind of low effort they don't
want to put that much effort into all
this well a lot of times it's not worth
it you know what I'm saying it's just
not worth it it's not worth a hassle is
what I'm saying guys are kind of
genetically built to try to spread seed
you know if if you leave them alone
they'll just collect a whole bunch of
yeah
girlfriends they'll just collect a bunch
of them there has to be a mechanism to
stop them from doing it yeah yeah if you
look at ancient societies that don't
have any of those mechanisms you got you
end up with like Genghis Khan the
[__] had two thousand two
thousand wives yeah yeah and impregnated
most of them evidently
he had a whole system of rotation and
everything every everybody on the planet
isn't [__] related to Genghis Khan
they probably all are I mean yeah like
not even that distantly yeah
and uh you know even to this day in the
Middle East you know a lot of those guys
have three three wives
even that sounds like too much work you
go down to [__] the Mormons the old
the the Mormon cults
uh not the mainstream Mormons but some
of the Breakaway Cults have multiple
wives but we've seen whole [__]
programs on them those dudes aren't
players man they're quite the opposite
yeah they're more like [__]
boob gangsters they're kicking all the
young boys out yeah so they can get like
all the 14 year olds
trading them like trading cards yeah
it's super creepy yeah that's not a good
situation and they'll have like 14 of
them yeah where's like I said
sounds like too much work mind control
occultists yeah yeah that was what what
was that documentary that was on Netflix
that we saw what was um be sweet and
Obey or whatever the [__] it was called
holy crap that was horrifying but the
science and the data is there you know
women are they're natural they're
natural mode of operation is hypergamy
they date up and over they want a guy
who has more money than them more status
than them looks better than them that's
that's what they'll tend to do
so all your average guys get to
get ignored they're all going for that
same top 20 percent of the men
and if you look at all the reported
statistics those guys at the top are
getting a [__] ton of girlfriends
and then all the girls all the girls are
reporting having sex a lot of sex too
but then most of the guys aren't
reporting having any sex and what it is
is that those girls are all [__]
those dudes
in the dating population
you know
once they're married it may change gears
into something else but um
and a lot of those guys have been
studying it for years now a lot of those
guys at the very top they don't get
married
or if they do is later
because there's nothing in it for them
why get married
they got married they wouldn't be able
to screw all these girls and it's like
the best ones
you know although even if they did get
married they probably still would so I
don't know what's happened well it just
makes it more of a hassle yeah that's
true it's better to just stay single so
they're waiting until they're [__] 40
or 50 to ever get married well like I
said they're slipping but I mean that's
kind of fine because you know the only
thing that's shitty about that like I
said you can [__] as many people as you
want you can do that but it's like just
don't [__] over the person that you're
making like you know your spouse or
whatever so it's like if you know that
you want to do that yeah oh I just want
to [__] everybody then just don't get
married yeah and just and just let
everybody know it's like hey I'm [__]
a bunch of people other than you and
it's like as long as everybody's on the
same page then it's fine but here's the
thing
also looked at this data these dudes
that have all this money and status and
all these girlfriends
the women that are chasing them if you
actually track their progress through
life they get [__]
well yeah because yeah that guy has all
that money and status but that's not
gonna help you nope you're gonna go
spend time with him through two three
months four months five months and he's
gonna dump you
because there's a lot of girls like you
he's just gonna replace you well yeah
he's he's in high demand
well a couple hundred years ago or
another culture maybe a thousand years
ago that guy would have just he would
have been the kind of guy that had
[__] nine wives
that's you know an event like that
so the situation that in the western
world now
with monogamy marriage between two
people is really kind of a middle class
fantasy that's not really the standard
Mo through most history it was
polygamy that was actually the standard
I mean that goes back even to ancient
Rome dude had as many wives as he could
afford
pretty much yep
and then the women were all about it
because they'd rather be with a high
status guy than some [__] beta simp
you know he didn't have anything she
wants they ignore all the the average
guys are ignored yeah they got it hard
people think that they are the
oppressors if not the average the
average guy is just a [__] drone
you know he's gonna work be alone most
of the time be passed over and he dies
that's basically what it is
most of them
so he's no
you know
it's women are kind of dictating the
dating Market men kind of dictate who
gets married
especially the rich guys
in England said Tom I had my first
accident on an off-road vehicle this
last weekend rolled down a hill on a
four-wheeler got up started that girl up
and went right back up I'm a little
[__] purple now yeah [__] man they
rolled over you it happens yeah I mean
it hasn't happened to me because I'm not
getting on one of those [__] things
it happened to me it mostly happened to
me when I was a kid
riding those things around in
Mississippi nearly killing ourselves
yeah yeah we'd be 14 years old [__]
riding those things [__]
out at my uh buddy David keys
Grand grandfather's place
he had a pond a couple of catfish ponds
it's probably about 10 15 acres and a
cement open field
he was bringing the catfish palms
and uh
we we [__] sneak beer down there and
get drunk and ride those [__]
four-wheelers and race them and [__]
wreck them but you're on dirt so you
know like I said this is why dudes don't
live as long as yeah
[Laughter]
this is this is why the Darwin Awards
books are yeah 99 dudes
we were [__] good
because we just don't do [__] like that
no I'm not saying that like women do
stupid [__] too but
not not to the same degree because you
kind of think about it's like well that
could go horribly I I immediately think
of like the million ways that ever that
it could go horribly wrong and I'm just
like yeah no I'm not gonna do that
uh Zach says if any of you have ever
eaten fried catfish yeah is that not a
Southern food yes it is I want to try it
I love Seafood
um any kind of fried fish is delicious
I'll eat pretty much anything that came
out of the ocean you know within reason
um fried catfish is really good yeah
it's very light very flaky
and it's a little bit oily the closest
other closest fish to it would be eel
it's kind of like eel yeah
um it's it's very fishy flavored so you
do kind of have to
I kind of feel like you have to really
like seafood like catfish maybe I don't
think it's fishy flavor well it's not as
mild as maybe some other fish like cod
or something is what I meant
I don't know how you cooked it but no
for us it was about like that
but the it's a lot lighter and a lot
flakier than Cod more like eel
it does have a flavor but it doesn't
taste like other fish it tastes more
like eel
yeah which that's not a bad thing you'll
taste good too
I don't know if I've ever had eel
strongest most fishiest fishy [__] I
can't even [__] eat it as salmon like
I just I love salmon instead
of salmon maybe I smoked salmon I've had
lox and [__] you know what I mean
[__] I've eaten canned salmon it is
fishy it is fishy tasting but I like it
though I always thought mackerel was
more fishy yeah
but I don't eat a lot of that but I love
salmon I could eat salmon all day long
yeah it is but it's very oily yeah Zach
said salmon is delicious yeah I'll eat
pretty much any kind of seafood you know
I really really like seafood a lot even
when we were when we were um at Disney
and [__] it's they had like um the one
restaurant we ate at
on Tuesday
was in the park and what was the [__]
name of it
Skipper canteen I think it's in
Adventureland and um I got a really nice
it was like this big slab of redfish
like pan-seared and it was on like all
of these fresh vegetables like in a
ginger broth and it was really really
good yeah but catfish is a very
primitive fish it's not like other fish
that you've eaten it doesn't even have
scales it's just got skin
and uh it's got poison barbs in its fins
and it's it's real primitive
I actually caught
um catfish one time as a kid and cleaned
them on the bank and threw everything
pretty much everything back in the in
the in the pond so the turtles would eat
it
because those things were [__] filled
with [__] snapping turtles
came back the next day to fish again
and notice that one I forgot to throw
one of the heads in it was still laying
up here on the bank and it was still
breathing that's how primitive they were
yeah that thing was still
the head was still alive it had been up
there for a little unsettling yeah
they've been up there for at least 18
hours and I just threw it in the water
also I mean remember when we used to
watch River Monsters all the time and
like Jeremy Wade catches some monster
[__] catfish sometimes like big
enough that they've killed people yeah
like their mouths were so big that you
could they could actually probably
swallow you that's how big those [__]
things you gotta scan them
you um before you cut the heads off you
gotta
hang them up on the side of a tree
usually with like
trying to remember what we used it was
just a nylon rope you go through the
mouth and the gills and you [__] you
tie a knot on rope around a tree where
there's a lamb like a pine tree and then
a another
rope you tie around it there and have a
hook see he'll hang there on a tree and
you just slice them around the head and
then slice the skin straight down the
belly you just cut the skin around the
head and straight down the belly
underside of it and then you take a pair
of pliers and just grab the skin and
pull the skin off as hard
and you pull the skin off while he's
still alive they they're just they don't
give a [__] though they'll still be they
might give a little bit of a visit
to be out already and he's just like oh
what's happening yeah and the head is
still breathing in your skin in it
that's a mess up and then you cut the
head off and then throw it down there
and put the next one on there and then
you're throwing them in a cooler
because you don't get that skin off
there it'll never really come off when
you cook it it'll just be stuck on there
and I think that's I think maybe that's
why you said it tastes real fishy
because we would skin them yeah and and
I only had it it only tasted light and
Flaky
so maybe if you cook it with the skin on
it maybe it's yeah it's stronger I don't
know
down here sometimes in some restaurants
you can get like catfish nuggets yeah
which I like those
but um and there's another kind of
Catfish called a mud cat we get those we
would throw them away
as soon as you caught it you threw it
back which kind of sucked because after
a while you start taking over the
[__] pond so then you make new rules
like enough you get a mud cat [__]
throw it on the bank and kill it
try to get rid of them it's like a
catfish but it's short or fatter
and they taste like mud now I guess
because they're eating mud they might be
silk sucking stuff out of the silt in
the bottom their bottom feeders
well that's what that's terrible that's
what they were that's what they've been
talking about like all these comments uh
Danny Rowling said Mississippi has the
best catfish farm restaurants in my area
uh Ian England said fried catfish is the
[__] I love a very spicy batter on it
yeah I love fried catfish honestly yeah
in Mississippi
um our catfish you stocked them you
built your own Pond and they had
companies that would come and stock your
pond for you it was cheap
and then you'd have
a couple years worth of [__] food out
there and maybe every two years you'd
have to come back and restock it because
your chances are you're gonna be
catching them faster than
they were born and then you had
snapping turtles were eating little ones
so there's an attrition rate in there
so all those farm raised catfish you're
talking about a real bigger Southern
families owned their own catfish Farms
on their land
you could have a thing stocked for
[__] 600 bucks
and you know
several several years where the [__]
free catfish
you know you can't beat it you used to
stock it with Russian boar too which is
a wild pig mixed with domestic
Pig
it was a Russian wild pig mixed with a
domestic Pig we called it Russian boar
and it had hair on it and tusks
but it was a half domestic
Pig we'd let those go
then we usually hunt them out in about
two years
they just couldn't keep up with the
demand
and they'd walk off your property too
so you had a keep her stocking them
yeah Camp guy said I think Mississippi
has the largest catfish agricultural
industry in the country but there may be
another state with more and then
um Camp guy also says I've heard those
giant catfish are not as good to eat and
England said giant ones start tasting
muddy yeah yeah Tammy said my mom used
to nail their heads to an old cutting
board and skin them yeah
yeah yeah
and then chances are they pull a head
off that nail and it would still be
[__] breathing they're [__] creepy
they're like a robot very unsettling
yeah Zack said I'd kill for there to be
a proper Cajun food restaurant around
here mom's from Louisiana so that's what
I grew up eating jambalaya yeah yeah
catfish days you made
Hush Puppies they cooked it in the same
grease you fried the fish in yeah
[__] catfish and Hot Pot hush puppies
and ketchup man
now I kind of want that yeah it's real
good
I wonder if Chantels is still down there
it's like still open they don't have
catfish though catfish no they don't
what did we usually get there like after
mannequins I forgot because they didn't
have the full menu chicken and waffles
yeah we'd get chicken and waffles
usually
shrimp and grits yeah but they don't
have shrimp and grits at night or they
didn't used to like we ate there a
couple times during the day and they had
it during the day because they're shrimp
and gritzes
at night man you got the girls working
and those girls are [__] terrible
service
they're very slow terrible because it's
like so well they're open till four in
the morning and they're just like man we
don't want to [__] deal with it they
don't really want to work
go in the day when Chantel's there and
she keeps them in line yeah
Camp guy said you use the nastiest bait
to fish for catfish chicken livers are
rotten dough actually
what we would do is
get
go to Piggly Wiggly all right
yeah and have old bread for sale over
there in the back
we we would throw like three loaves of
bread into the uh
into the pond every couple days
they'd eat that
and that would stir them up because it
was feeding time
and then we would just take a treble
hook the three Barbed hook and mash a
bunch of Velveeta cheese on it and throw
that in
and we would do it on a damn
on a cane pole
you could be in a boat because you just
hear little plastic boats we had these
little plastic boats go out through the
cane pole and just drop the [__]
bait in the water and there's an instant
bite boom you pull him out and just keep
going
so the bait we use a lot of time was
Velveeta cheese
smash it on the and then when you got
desperate you'd run out of Velveeta
cheese just put the hook in and a lot of
times they'd bite just the hook
because you know fish are they're not
that smart yeah but here one uses I'm
gonna put my mouth on it if you had
cheese on it it was an instant bite boom
after you stirred them up all species
love cheese yeah
well velveet is not really cheese
it's whey protein but the fish know what
it is yeah
they're like Velveeta
yeah Ian England said the river's here
in Central Missouri are loaded with
catfish yeah like I said now I kind of
want some catfish nuggets and some we've
tried to figure out if we could eat
snapping turtles you can't eat them
I mean yeah I'm not I don't taste it I
think I've eaten turtle one time in my
whole entire life and I just can't had a
whole Pond of [__] snapping turtles
and we're trying to figure out if we
could eat them the it never worked out
they're not a good we just killed him
I saw one I saw one in the pond at my
brother's Resort yeah like uh on yeah
you know outside of on Disney property I
saw a little I saw a little snap in
Turtle heads okay I'd be putting I was
like hey some Summers I'd be put on
missions to go down and just [__]
entire flush out entire ponds of like my
dad's friends and Dad's relatives
[__] flush flush out all the [__]
snapping turtles
so what what had been done over the
years people would throw logs and big
limbs up on the bank
and you got on the opposite bank and all
those Turtles to get up on top of those
logs
and you sat on the opposite side with a
sandbag sandbag rest and a 22 long rifle
rifle and sit there all day long
shooting [__] Turtles
well one time my dad had this [__] 22
250.
which is 308 neck down to 22.
and he had a [__] ton of Wildcat
cartridges so you had to make that you
had to make 22 250 using reloading dies
they were half 308 loaded dies and half
556 loading dies
and he must have had about a thousand
rounds of that
and he was just trying to get rid of it
because 22 250 is out of [__] Style
and they were going to re-barrel that
[__] rifle to something else to
another caliber
which was easy to do in Mississippi as
all the guys are there I didn't know how
to do it
and um so you wanted me to shoot up all
that 22 250 and I sat there
[__] all day killing Turtles with a
22 250 and it was a [__] sight to see
it's a little bitty 55 grain bullet
moving it like [__]
3 900 feet a second it's [__]
screaming those barrels don't last long
because it's so in the the heat is so
intense and the pressure's so intense in
that Barrel that it burns all the
rifling out of it the [__] life of
that Barrel is like maybe 800 rounds
and I had a thousand rounds of this [__]
at that range it was still accurate
though after I but I burned that Barrel
out and uh
those 22 rounds would hit a turtle the
turtle was probably about you know size
of a pancake
and it had a scope on it bolt action
rifle and it would hit that turtle and
it would turn that [__] Turtle into a
[__] pink Mist just an explosion of
pink and then you see [__] arms and
legs and shell fragments skipping across
the water like you you know
and then you just wait a few seconds and
another turtle jump up and take his
place
because they're all they were they
didn't know what was happening they were
just trying to get on top of the
get some sun you know but you were there
look I'm just trying to get something
yeah and try to warm my blood up and all
this they're eating all the baby fish
though so then they're like cockroaches
you can't eat them
so you just have to extinguish them
I must have killed [__] 700 of them
easily on that one day
ranging from about the size of a pancake
to like the size of a silver dollar
because you can see them in the scope
that was a [__] Slaughter that day
I also shot some crows I remember that
shout out there what did you shoot crows
for because you're not it was a farm and
it was kind of like uh you know kill the
crows that's just kind of like the
[__]
one of the
one of the standing orders is that if
you see a crowd just shoot the crows
they cause a lot of [__] trouble
there was a reason for it but I forgot
what it was Camp guy said I saw an
amazing fish and chips the dude coated
and dropped the fish into the fryer
waited about 30 seconds and then he
poured more of the coating on top of the
fish while it was cooking huh that it
had a giant crispy breading Mohawk
attached to the fried fish fillet I
think the channel is called not another
Cooking Channel yeah man fish and chips
is one of the world's greatest Pleasures
yeah I really love fish and chips yeah
yeah like I said when we were at Epcot
and we were in the British Pavilion
because of course my brother had to get
beer because he drank the whole time but
um
they had like a
a big restaurant there that has like
fish and chips and I was really tempted
but I was like man we're gonna eat a big
dinner later so I better not that
British stuff but it smelled so good
British style fish and chips we eat that
in Mississippi in the South they eat
that yeah we like the vinegar and
everything
yeah similar it is similar but but in
the southern version of this catfish
catfish and brim or bluegill yeah which
is so just a little white fish it's like
a big it's like a discus type fish man
we used to catch brim yeah bluegill
the boat with them
uh uh Zach says did I mention I have a
meeting set up with a rabbi so you are
really gonna do that [__] you're really
gonna okay what you gonna do is you
become Jewish yeah he's gonna convert
yeah but he's he's gonna convert to
Judaism so he can get dick ain't that
some [__] well hey ain't that some [__]
you gays are [__] amazing
I guess they gotta read at least he's
got a reason that's a pretty good reason
okay
I'm not converting to [__] for [__] I'm
just saying that right now there's a
dude we used to do at the club no dick
is good enough to for me to convert to
any religions
there was this dude we knew in the club
man he looked just like Brad Pitt for a
while he called himself Brad spit he was
like the ghetto version of bread
and he converted to Islam for a while
because he he liked Arabic oh I remember
that yeah yeah that didn't work out
those dudes drove him out of there
like I said it's you'd be hard-pressed
to convert to anything like that
I don't I don't care how good the dick
is because I'm not converting to
anything I don't do that I don't I don't
do that I don't do that religion thing
sorry
um
I know well here oh I was going to tell
you there was a question for you and I
was going to give it to you and then I
was good and then I was and then I was
gonna ask the question says Tom the Navy
and army are announcing that they will
test for steroids in Special Forces yeah
what do you think how many will get
popped
if they're any good all of them
um no the the military all the military
branches are not what they were not
during the time that I was in I was in
in a time when the military was the just
the U.S army was just the [__] best
it had ever been
which is for the first Gulf War
we had
that was the only time really in
American history where we had definitive
[__]
military Supremacy over all other
countries in the United States
and um people today in the united states
are under this and especially in
Washington DC are under a delusion that
we still have that Supremacy we don't
right now
world-class Army of the world is the
Russian army they're the baddest land
Army probably to have ever [__]
existed
they destroyed the Ukraine Army three
times over but they haven't told you
that the only thing only guys that are
there a bunch of old men and probably
young boys maybe they've stooped that
low
and they're not trained and they're just
sitting there in cauldronated
well the [__] Russians are just
[__] hitting with artillery strikes
and they're using psychological
operations on them giving them
instructions on how to surrender they're
surrendering in Mass
Russia won that arm one that war almost
a year ago as soon as they got them and
called or entered into the dumbass that
was it
and uh most of the US military right now
is obsolete it's just that you don't
know it yet
things like aircraft carriers Jets and
tanks and all that [__] expensive
garbage is only good against third world
countries that can't fight back because
they don't have a response to that
any country that has Hypersonic weapons
and [__] satellite technology
they're they're going to beat us
resoundly
and there's no way to fight Russia
because everything has to be shipped
over to Europe and they're [__]
submarine Fleet and those [__]
Hypersonic missiles that they have will
[__] send every [__] ship to the
bottom so there's no way to get on the
European continent
and we don't and we don't for us
hypersonics are 15 years away
it'll never happen
so
it doesn't matter how good our military
is or how bad it is
because they're only really going to use
it against third world countries
and those days are running out man
[__] Africa in the Middle East
they're [__] sick of us they've
joined bricks
and Russia and China with bricks they'll
defend them so the days of the American
Empire are over
thank God thank God Ian England said you
need somebody who grew up eating
snapping turtles because my buddy's dad
makes them taste real good yeah I guess
so there must be a secret to it we could
never get it to taste good so I mean I
kind of feel like with most things
there's a secret to making it taste well
maybe not with everything but you know
what I mean
Danny rolling said I'd rather crab cakes
and chips well [__] that's good too I
love crab cakes also uh yeah he says all
you can eat crab cakes at a buffet would
be awesome I agree uh except it would
probably be really dangerous for me
because I would just eat that just eat
all of those
Zach says uh legit though I just really
like the people and the culture is
interesting have some friends who are
Jewish some of the best friends I've
ever had yeah we're not we're just
[__] with him
but yeah I get it
okay Danny Rowling says oh wait till he
comes back but it's um the 1989
Andrew Davis the film The Package
starring Gene Hackman as an Army Ranger
I've never heard of that actually in
huh
we'll have to look that up because I
don't think I've ever heard of that
movie
even though I was watching a lot of
movies in 1989 and 1990 so you think I
would have seen it but no
man now I want now I want crab cakes
and then now I'm trying to remember like
to wait did we eat today
yeah I guess we did
uh uh what should we eat today I can't
remember oh we had a burger at about 11
30 or noon
and that's it oh we haven't eaten since
then okay no wonder I'm getting hungry
that's probably what it is
but yeah so uh we'll just probably have
to go out without eating and then we'll
eat when we get back we'll probably stop
at Circle K on the way home and get
sandwiches and stuff because I was
sitting there thinking I'm [__]
hungry man I am on the way out
well because I was just thinking it's
like yeah we had a burger but that was
like a long time nine hours ago
we just we forget I mean well we're on
calorie restrictions that too that too
but uh
what uh we have to leave here around
nine right like nine yeah we still got
like 15 minutes yeah we actually should
probably go now though because maybe we
should stop and get something to eat on
the way over there well I can't eat
anything because I have of course that's
corset on so I'll probably have to get
some on the way home okay
um even something small through
McDonald's
we don't pass a McDonald's do we yes we
do oh that's right yeah we do on the way
to Sanford I forgot I forgot we were
going to yeah I'm going to Sanford um
I don't know I guess maybe I could eat
some or we could stop at [__] Circle
K and just get a sandwich and eat it on
a run although like I said I don't know
I can make a sandwich here maybe
I don't know
I don't know maybe I don't know we'll
think of something don't don't maybe
think of something like where I'm alone
sitting here uh Danny Rowling said Tom
you probably like the 1989 Andrew B
Davis film called the package starring
Gene Hackman as an Army Ranger who
stumbles onto an assassination attempt
on the Russian president to start a war
it's a great film yeah like I said I
never uh heard of that so maybe we
should try to look I think I have heard
of it yeah yeah I think I remember that
said it's also a Christmas film yeah is
it
yeah um just you guys are going to see
the [__] unfold I don't know how much
you're into geopolitics and everything
but uh uh don't believe a [__] single
word you hear off of any corporate news
Outlet that's all CIA propaganda
all that [__] got encodified during the
[__] that last war where they did
that Patriot Act they made it legal to
[__] for the CIA to propagandize the
American public
so they're just sitting up there lying
through their [__] teeth
uh about what's happening now and uh
it's all grift they're just trying to
get free money for the
military-industrial [__] complex make
contracts and [__] the danger is is that
some of these dudes that are in
Washington DC are so stupid and they're
[__] stupid uh they're they're badly
educated they don't know anything about
[__] history they know nothing about
Russian culture the Russian history they
think they can beat Russia on Russia's
soil they're [__] crazy
they will never beat them
um I don't think we could have beat them
when we were strong even back in the 80s
early 90s
even with before the Soviet Union
collapsed they probably would have
[__] us up pretty bad because they're
on that continent they don't have to
ship anything there
can sit right there and make tanks all
[__] day long that's how they [__]
whipped ass on [__] Russia excuse me
so they whipped ass on [__] Germany
and France and England they [__]
England up too
I think that was 1700 1600s the English
one
um
Crimean War I think we'll go
and then uh Napoleon there [__] his
ass up they just got home
Home Advantage and they have [__] a
[__] ton of [__] natural resources
and they'll just go to slave labor they
don't need money they don't need money
Russians are
patriotic
they'll do just like they did with the
with the Germans is that they'll just
sit there on a [__] concrete slab
making tanks in the middle of [__]
snow not a dime that maybe they give him
a [__] piece of bread
Russians are [__] strong-willed
they're tough I know I was friends with
one of them ex-russian infantry guy
named Vadim conyev and I showed him to
Jen man he was a goth guy [__] after
the fall [__] we were hanging out
[__] Bosley Jim was like oh he's cute
yeah you look like a [__] Russian
Antonio Banderas [__] hair down to
his waist
had a whole hair my strippers living up
in his house he ran a damn little
computer store
told me all about the Russian army
it's like ours really but he just he
watched it all fall apart it was
must have been a [__] astounding to
just see a civilization just vanish
like vaporware just like an overnight
but they no longer believed in it
yeah probably so
all right so they had been lying to him
for so long everybody knew everybody was
lying
so
there was nothing but fake news and it
Soviet Union had lost confidence and the
people just said [__] us I'm not gonna
do this anymore
and it just vanished
but millions of people died Millions
starvation suicide alcoholism
girls ran off to foreign countries to
become prostitutes and never never seen
again just all kinds of [__] it was a
cataclysm for them and if and it's
they're traumatized man the Russians
have been traumatized over and over
again going all the way back to [__]
Ivan to terrible who arriving to Great
whoever I think it was great too he was
terrible and great
they're bad asses
okay so are you ready to wrap it up
because you said we you wanted we gotta
go okay so it was just I was waiting for
you stop talking yeah uh all right so
we're gonna go out this evening so we
have to sign off we'll be back again on
Monday doing a movie review I don't know
what movie it's gonna be because we
haven't watched it yet uh maybe we'll
look up that Gene Hackman one and see
how see if we can find that somewhere
and watch that if we remember but yeah
so hopefully you guys can join us again
on Monday please have a good and safe
weekend you guys and we will see you
again on Monday good